hi I'm Erik Bosse and this is a
breakdown of Rick and Morty season 3
episode 8 Morty's mind blowers this was
season threes interdimensional cable
episode and while not all the bits may
have been as memorable this episode was
still full of fun subtle Easter eggs and
crazy conspiracy theories and real quick
big thanks to our friends that quit for
sponsoring this video
quid is an app that allows you to drag
and drop stickers onto text message
threads including brick and mortar
themed ones more info on that later ok
let's get started by talking about the
deeper meaning of this episode so
Morty's mind blowers presents this
premise that all of Morty's darkest
memories are wiped from his mind and
stored in a vault and won't win the
episode they have this key exchange I
mean maybe it stopped making so many if
I let myself learn from them don't break
your back creating a lesson Morty it's a
free-form anthology I'm getting annoyed
you're not hearing that so this isn't
just Rick's commentary on this kind of
episode where we shouldn't dig too deep
to find meaning from it it's actually a
statement about this series as a whole
Rick and Morty do not allow themselves
to learn last episode I talked about the
illusion of change on the show how each
episode seems to end with a major
breakthrough but it doesn't stick and
they're back to where they started the
next episode so this is Dan Harmon and
Justin roiland critique of the sitcom
genre in order to keep the laughs
flowing for as many seasons as possible
classic sitcom characters never grow or
learn from their mistakes the writers
instead trap them in an endless cycle of
bad behavior
now genre wise Rick and Morty is a great
sitcom like the others but it goes a
step further it explains the cyclical
sitcom structure in the universe this
episode defines it as a choice made by
the characters they trapped themselves
in cycles of bad behavior Rick and Morty
don't want to learn from their mistakes
because their mistakes are too painful
they've caused death and suffering for
innocent Millions
in fact we see how even a mistake as
simple as flipping the wrong light
switch leads to the deaths of people and
then the other side of the galaxy
now this episode's thematic ancestors
season ones Rick's T minutes aka the
first interdimensional Cable in which
Rick and Morty laid out what was to me
the first clear thesis statement for
this series nobody exists on purpose
nobody belongs anywhere everybody's
gonna die come watch TV and this episode
reinforces that idea by ending the
episode the same way watching an
interdimensional cable for Rick and
Morty TV is meant as an escape from real
pain
true Rick and Morty style there has to
be a logical reason for that escape to
be possible and in Morty's mind blowers
we learned that core life-changing
memories being blown from the mind isn't
merely a plot hole trope of the sitcom
genre it's the life
Rick and Morty choose now before the
opening credits rig breaks the fourth
wall by calling out what this episode is
and we'll be doing this instead of
interdimensional cable but later in the
episode he says this like a clip show
made of clips you never saw this is
actually a reference to Dan Harmon's
previous sitcom community the season 2
episode paradigms of human memory was a
clip show featuring clips two episodes
that we had never seen before on the
show let's break down all of this
episode's cultural references and
influences in our segment under the
influence so Rick's vault has
differently colored memories based on
who wanted the memory erased blue for
Morty red for Rick and purple for the
rest of the family in the background
there's also a yellow and green vials
that we never got to see you may have
caught that these are the same five
memory colors for the Pixar film inside
out and it might be a stretch but it's
kind of like the five associated
emotions kind of match up here remember
blue were for sad memories in here they
show up every time Morty is depressed
about something that he did read were
four angry memories and here they show
memories when Rick was really pissed off
about something purple were for the
fearful memories and maybe in this case
they were for Beth and summers fear that
Morty will know Beth loves summer more
than him and if that holds true for the
rest maybe yellow memories are for ones
that were too joyful for Morty like ones
associated with Jessica and Green could
be the ones that were too disgusting
associated maybe with like toxic Morty
now actually the opening scene contains
a few influences as well the design of
this whole temple is based on MC
Escher's famous print relativity you
might also remember that design from the
movie labyrinth and yeah the guy chasing
them looks a lot like David Bowie's
character for that movie but I would say
his design seems more influenced by Neil
Gaiman's Sandman from the DC Comics now
Morty has stolen the tortoise of truth
which could be a reference to the deity
figure mature in the turtle from Stephen
King's novels The Dark Tower series in
it this tortoise gives Morty infinite
knowledge just like how mature and gives
characters divine insight and notice how
the tortoise says something to Morty
here
[Music]
now if this sounded like reverse audio
to you
yeah rude so let's actually see what
this says backwards I love this that was
Justin roiland voice saying I'm a Beatle
Paul is dead which is a reference to the
famous Beatles Paul is dead conspiracy
theory based on John Lennon mumbling
some gibberish throughout the White
Album at the end of the song
I'm so tired you can hear some things
being said when you play the audio
backwards to some people it sounded like
all this dead man missa missa missa me
king of conspiracy theories if you look
closely at the background of this temple
you can see statues and carvings of The
Tortoise and it looks like he's holding
an all-seeing eye within a triangle
which is a symbol that some people
associate with the Illuminati
now some people are also saying this
could be a reference to bill cipher from
gravity falls since it appears to have
eyelashes gravity falls creator Alex
Hirsch tweeted that this wasn't the case
because he's not wearing a top hat
come on guys let's get real but bill
cipher from gravity falls does show up
somewhere else this episode one of the
memory vials is labeled bill C and
another one right next to it is labeled
Stanford which is a nod to the full name
of Ford Pines and gravity falls now the
memory called mortise menagerie is a
reference to a classic episode of Star
Trek called the caves where an advanced
race of aliens called the two oceans
trap other species in these cages and
force them to mate actually they're
round bulbous heads might have been an
influence on this light bulb headed dude
here he might have actually been
inspired by the collector from the
Marvel Universe and then this memory
turned into an homage to the Jodie
Foster movie contact which was actually
referenced back in the were lead early
episode just like in contact
Rick contacts this scientist through a
signal to the VLA in New Mexico with
instructions to transport herself
through a wormhole and then he pretends
to be an advanced alien race taking
human form forms your mind can accept we
thought this might make things easier
for you
and then this shot of the two scientists
holding hands as they look out the
window at their doom this is the exact
same framing of David Fincher's closing
shot of the movie Fight Club next up
this Floop Floop Ian's memory ends with
him getting hit by a car and his soul
being dragged down to his version of
Hell which is a reference to the movie
ghost
[Applause]
whoo that is terrifying in a later
memory Rick cuts open Bebo so that he
and Morty can warm themselves in his
guts which is a pretty clear nod to the
Empire Strikes Back when Han cuts open
the tonton to use its guts to warm Luke
now my favorite of these memories is
morty walking on the perfectly level
surface and then freaking out when he
realizes that the rest of the universe
is crooked now that phrase lamps to the
slaughter is an old biblical and
literary term meaning helpless innocence
unaware of the horror of their reality
roald dahl actually wrote a horror novel
with that as a title now in the
squirrels memory which I also really
loved there's a few influences here now
that is a reference to dr. Dolittle a
movie about a scientist who can
understand animals Morty also briefly
whistles the theme of the movie the
bridge on the river kwai and the way the
hordes of squirrels line up menacingly
around the garage visually recalls the
iconic image of Alfred Hitchcock's the
birds like Morty with the squirrels the
birds gradually assemble around the
target and prepare to attack now one of
the quick montage memories shows Morty
as a ghost while Rick searches for him
he's wearing a proton pack here which is
a reference to Ghostbusters and the
interdimensional cable show they watched
is a parody of the HG TV show house
hunters but in this version houses our
actual creatures that are literally
being hunted and of course the
post-credits scene with Morty and his
friends on bikes trying to send Cobo to
his own planet is a reference to ET the
extra-terrestrial now of course there's
one big memory that I'm skipping over
and it's because I found it to be really
weird moon spirit see now there are two
things that I found interesting about
this one I think it could be a reference
to the classic Twilight Zone episode
nightmare at 20,000 feet
we're like Morty a character spots this
creepy figure that no one else believes
exists but I also think there's a lot
more to this guy but before I get to
that theory we got to pay the bills real
quick and thank our friends from kwid
for sponsoring this video long as we
probably couldn't even do this stuff for
you guys quid is an app where you can
collect cool stickers cards and Funko
figures for free all on your phone if
you use emojis and stickers when you
text your friends quit as thousands of
free stickers that you can't find
anywhere else from shows like the just
release Game of Thrones Rick
Morty's Steven universe Bob's Burgers
Powerpuff Girls and Family Guy cult hits
like Breaking Bad and Star Trek and for
games like five nights at Freddy's and
fallout it's easy you can drag and drop
these stickers on iMessage
look Rick's yelling my texts and if you
collect Funko pop figures quit has those
too now some of these stickers cards and
toys are super rare and hard to get so
good luck but good news is you can meet
cool people on QuIDD look at their
collections and trade with them just as
easily and as quickly as chatting with
each other there's also a new feature
you can showcase suit collection by
adding stickers to images you already
have in a camera roll just look over at
your profile to have an iOS new stickers
cards and figures that you can collect
for free are released every day
including the surprise big news show
that's coming soon ok let's get back to
this guy mr. Lumis now the end of the
memory makes it seem like Morty's seen
him on the moon was really just a smudge
on the telescope lens but there are a
lot of mysterious clues around the guy
that tell a different story
so let's activate the theory time okay
so first obvious clue notice how his
name is mr. Lunas modified form of the
word lunar as in related to the moon but
then a little less obvious notice when
Morty initially sees him mr. Lunas has a
shadow on the moon now if he was just a
smudge he wouldn't have a shadow here
right now you could say this shadow is
just Morty's mind playing tricks on I'm
sure but look at Lunas his license plate
SAT f1 v3 I'm thinking that could be a
reference to these Saturn 5 those are
the Rockets that took the NASA
astronauts to the moon and then finally
mr. Luna says house number is 3 7 now
237 is a meaningful number it's a
reference to these shining room 237 is
the name of the room in the Overlook
Hotel that Danny is warned to never go
into it's where Jack encounters the
ghost of the nude woman room 237 is also
the name of a documentary about the
shining where a bunch of film theorists
share their nutty interpretations of the
film including one that claims the
shining contains subliminal messages
from Stanley Kubrick that he faked the
moon landing in 1969 see where I'm going
this Oh No ok I think what Morty
perceived was real and I think it was
evidence of a conspiracy that in the 60s
Rick helped NASA faked the moon landing
using his friend Lunas who's some kind
of being that doesn't breathe oxygen
just think about it Rick confessed to
editing memories later on in this
episode so maybe he killed Lunas and
covered it up as a suicide and we know
from past episodes that Rick's mind does
occasionally drip to NASA astronauts
it's probably a bad time to mention it
but any astronauts you guys had an
orbiter definitely dead okay okay these
things are probably not connected but I
like to think the writers left us all
open-ended enough to make this [ __ ]
possible either way I think we could all
agree that it would have been nice to
hear goodbye moon man playing during
this guy's funeral actually speaking of
goodbye moon man let's point out all of
this episode series continuity
references in our segment callbacks okay
so there are a few callbacks to Morty's
dog snuffles from the first season the
portrait of snuffles in the house shows
up the background behind Morty when he
looks through the telescope and then
later one of the memories shows Morty's
head-on snuffles body also the
Collector's menagerie cages are filled
with miserable callbacks a few of them
are these same alien races as Rick's
buddies from Rick's II business there's
a couple of them including the Trev
lorkans
also if you look closely there are a few
female gazorpazorp osorb and if you look
really closely for just a few frames you
can barely make out a few weary looking
mr. meeseeks in another cage Oh II look
at them now summers band NERD friend
Nancy makes another cameo in the
post-credits scene and earlier there's a
quick cameo by mr. poopy butthole who's
briefly seen proposing a Morty now that
post-credits scene was one of Jerry's
wiped memories which instead of the
color-coded vials they take the form of
these old tapes and notice the other
memories in their capital campaign and
sleepy Gary those are callbacks to
Jerry's failed Apple advertising
campaign and season ones and night some
aliens and his imaginary affair with
sleepy Gary in season two's Total Recall
now earlier I pointed out the gravity
falls Easter eggs with the memory labels
there's actually a lot of other stuff
happening here so let's point out all
these other subtle animation details and
hour segments zoom in enhance okay so
all of these labels have dumb names on
them including a few hidden Dickey's
here like balls and tit one of them just
says the word virginity and notice I
would say read Rick removed memory which
is kind of messed up because why would
Rick want morty losing his virginity to
be removed
Oh God that could be gross now there are
also a few little throwaway details like
principal vagina
doodlee and stick figures in his planner
and then a pizza Friday poster in the
NASA office and then the grocery store
that about to go shopping in called
vomits grocery but here notice this
Mexican restaurant
jong-kook oh this is actually a
real-life Mexican restaurant in Burbank
it's not too far from the Adult Swim
office so it's very possible that
roylene and the other riders eat at that
place and then decided to animate it
into the show and then let's pause on
that list of instructions that some are
read to restore Rick and Morty's
memories notice the last one when Rick
and Morty awake leave the room and I
like how the end of this episode pays
that off with Rick and Morty custody now
it's over for no reason it's like Rick
knew how much of an [ __ ] they would
be when they woke up and if summer left
the room is instructed she would have
avoided that okay coming out of zooming
enhance I want to point out a few more
details that I really liked this episode
first notice when Rick makes fun a break
for saying it as take things for granted
it's granted with addy take things for
granted did you actually think it was
Jesus Christ Rick what are you a boulder
a rock person this is actually kind of a
callback to the first time rock people
came up this episode just our luck
menagerie beneath the boulder people of
granite or seven there was also the
closing line of the episode no wonder
you're constantly fighting with each
other and behind schedule what nothing
this is kind of a meta joke about that
rumor that the reason rick and morty
season three was delayed was that harmon
in royland were fighting which wasn't
true and then there was this interesting
moment at the end of the squirrel story
you [ __ ] with squirrels Morty we got a
good five minutes before they're backing
up on our ass Morty we need to pack up
and move to a new reality Morty you know
we said we could only do that a couple
of times
pause so this is interesting up until
now we assume that Rick and Morty only
swapped into a new reality one time
after Cronenberg in their homes c-137
dimension but now it appears to have
happened at least one other time so this
definitely supports the theory that i
brought up in the last breakdown that
the visiting rick and morty from the
citadel just then realized where our
rick and morty were after rick killed
the council of ricks and even though in
season one the council still knew where
rick was after the swath in rick potion
number nine when they showed up in
clothes for counters with rick kind now
that we know he swapped another time
that may mean that he's gone back into
hiding since that encounter which of
Morty's my
what was your favorite let me know in
the comments below or by tweeting me at
ei vas and subscribe to new rockstars
and because we love you guys so much and
because you were nice enough to stick
around to the end of the video we're
gonna do a giveaway
Rick and Morty Funko pop vinyl figures
follow us on Twitter and share this
video on Twitter with the hashtag new
wick stars and we'll pick a couple of
you at random and send you guys a free
Rick and Morty Funko pop vinyl figure so
there you go tweet away thank you so
much for watching
bye